in the heart of london demanding more be
done for ukraine many of these
protesters are ukrainian with family and
friends back home that they're
desperately worried about
people like ella medvedeva who came to
britain more than 20 years ago
i still remember stories from my
grandmother and great father about the
second world war and how the fascists
came and it's
just happening again and it's not just
it's not just the
military right
objects infrastructure they're killing
people
there were similar solidarity protests
across europe this was munich in the
south of germany itself no stranger to
upheaval and dark episodes in history
we are worried about our brothers
sisters our relatives you look at the
people gathered here and everybody is
scared the war will break out in europe
in the italian capital a large crowd
called for more pressure on russia
and in paris they gathered in the place
de la republique calling on nato to
protect ukraine's airspace
that was a key demand in london too i
think we should be supporting militarily
ukraine as best as possible
there's a mad man at the moment in in
the kremlin and
i mean we have to we have to do what we
can the crowd here has been chanting
glory to ukraine and denouncing the
russian president but they've also been
calling for specific measures they want
britain to take right now including
greater financial sanctions and more
military help for ukraine's armed forces
and while the ukrainian flag now flies
from government buildings many are angry
there's no legal route for most
ukrainians to seek asylum in britain we
need to be letting refugees come in
and just scrap visas for them all to get
here and then once they're here deal
with it whatever afterwards for now all
ukrainians outside the country can do is
hope the fighting ends soon and urge the
world to do more to make that happen
nadine barber al jazeera london